hey youtubers is Charlie so hopefully
you've all had a chance to see Doctor
Strange by now so this is gonna be my
top picks for what I think they should
do next with the character especially
considering Avengers infinity war just
careful for spoilers for everything that
happened during Doctor Strange so the
really exciting thing is we're actually
gonna be seeing some Doctor Strange
really soon we know that because of the
post-credits scene so number one just
flat-out hold off on a direct Doctor
Strange sequel like Doctor Strange 2
until phase 4 because they have about
eight more films in phase three that go
up till May of 2019 that'll be the
second Avengers infinity war film
leaving the fall of 2019 like later that
year for whatever they want to start
phase four with so right off the bat
they could start fall 2019 with Doctor
Strange - and pick up on some of the big
things that they teased that were
happening at the end of the first Doctor
Strange movie that's really like the
easiest thing for them to do because
they do have to follow up on those plot
threads the biggest ones being the
threat of Dormammu which I'll talk about
in a second because I don't think that
he's going to be a big villain for a
long long time into the more immediate
threat of Baron Mordo
killing off magic users so I think you
know like next big Doctor Strange movie
it'll be Doctor Strange versus Baron
Mordo and it'll be the culmination of
his ascension to sorcerer supreme
because at the end of this movie even
though he wielded the eye of a komodo
the time gem the ancient one said that
she saw great potential in him he is not
the sorcerer supreme so currently there
is not one on earth right now a lot of
that arc will take place over the course
of Phase three so just like the Hulk
gets like a really big story stretched
out over a bunch of other people's films
dr. Strange's story of his ascension to
sorcerer supreme will kind of cross over
a bunch of films but a lot of times
they'll save the biggest twist for
characters for their solo films in
becoming sorcerer supreme is a huge deal
so they would probably save that moment
like the final moment of that when he
becomes sorcerer supreme for the next
Doctor Strange movie but I know I just
talked about Dormammu we know that he's
a big threat what I think is gonna
happen
I think we're all kind of in agreement
that he's such a big threat that they'll
just save him for like the next big
thing afterthe annos the director of
scott derrickson is even having a little
bit of fun with that idea too so the
heroes will deal with Thanos during both
of the infinity war films then Dormammu
will slowly move in and become a bigger
threat so number three Doctor Strange
and Thor Ragnarok crossover movie it's
really more of a Thor movie with Doctor
Strange in it but like I said throughout
phase 3 we'll see a lot of Doctor
Strange sometimes it'll be very brief
sometimes it'll be much bigger Thor you
could think of it as a big crossover
because it's a pretty big plot point
helping them track down Odin on earth so
that they can get back to Asgard deal
with hella and the Ragnarok monsters so
I'll even say I'm totally cool with them
pushing off a direct Doctor Strange
sequel so that they can do more stuff
like that more team-up movies in Kevin
Feige did tease that the phase four
movies will look a lot different from
the way they structured the phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 movies which I think
just means a lot more team-ups so like
even if we don't see an Iron Man sequel
actually I'll go ahead and say number 4
Doctor Strange
Iron Man team-up which i think is a good
option for both actors because at this
point Robert Downey jr. is so expensive
and he's getting to that age where it's
like you know what kind of story haven't
we done yet what is there that he's
capable of doing that people want to buy
movie tickets for so I just think the
idea of working with Benedict
Cumberbatch would excite Robert Downey
jr. enough to get him to do a movie so
the problem with that is that if you're
gonna put iron man in Doctor Strange in
a movie together and it's gonna be like
there buddy roadtrip comedy movie you
need to have a villain with one foot in
the realm of science and one foot in the
realm of magic and who is that in the
Marvel Universe
well that is Doctor Doom and they don't
have access to him right now he would be
a perfect villain for Doctor Strange
Ironman team-up but I'm not gonna hold
my breath for Fox sharing the character
so they might be able to do a version of
the Mandarin a lava ten rings they did
that short film called hail to the king
where they tease the idea that there is
a real Mandarin who is in the world
somewhere we just haven't seen him yet
you know who knows if they'll ever
surface but
if you read some of the furor over the
recasting of Tilda Swinton like the way
they cast that character how like a lot
of people felt like it was really
insensitive there was a whole bunch of
drama behind it just imagine them trying
to do the Mandarin character and then
selling the movie in China so it's just
a huge landmine that they don't want to
step on so even though it would be
awesome to see the Mandarin whose rings
come from an alien race so there's your
science right there but they're also
imbued with their own level of
intelligence so you have some
supernatural so you know Mandarin would
be a good villain for Doctor Strange
Ironman team-up as long as he did have
the ten rings but I don't think that
Marvel is gonna do that so they might
just save you know Doctor Strange
Ironman team-up solo film for whenever
they can get a villain that they feel
like is big enough or they can actually
get Doctor Doom flat out but Kevin Feige
himself was just saying how excited he
was at the thought of Benedict
Cumberbatch in scenes as Doctor Strange
with Robert Downey jr. as Tony Stark
just seeing those two characters
interact with each other in seeing how
crazy it gets so we'll actually get a
taste of that when we get to infinity
war so it's still a little ways off but
it's coming next big idea is a Doctor
Strange multiverse treasure hunt
treasure hunt is always a ton of fun you
know very swashbuckling adventure but
because it's Doctor Strange he's not
bound by time or space he can go all
over the multiverse if you remember the
2001 Space Odyssey montage where the
ancient were just kind of like pushes
him on a trip through the multiverse
just to give him a taste of what's out
there just imagine a pretty straight up
treasure hunt story where he's tracking
down dangerous magical artifacts along
the way he crosses paths with people
like Mephisto Dormammu again just a
little bit you want to keep him off in
the distance you don't wanna do too much
of him too soon but that would be more
of like a straight-up national treasure
type story with Marvel characters so it
wouldn't be quite as crazy but then you
know the last big idea would be like a
team magic film so if you really wanted
to you could do like a baron mordo Loki
team up against Doctor Strange Scarlet
Witch in any of the other magical
characters that we see along the way
because there are a lot of characters
they just haven't introduced yet so
really you could put anyone in that
movie who has the power of an infant
you know depending on what their status
is after the second infinity war film
but I know a lot of you were wondering
you like what about comic book stories
well you know most of the stuff that
they do in the movies are amalgams of
comic books and we've already seen all
this big stuff that they set up in the
first film like staff of the Living
Tribunal all these magical artifacts
story points like Dormammu what's going
on with Baron Mordo they have to carry
those forward so largely you kind of
know what they're going to be doing with
any sequel that they do but the other
big thing is just mixing in the other
Marvel characters like we kind of saw
some Marvel vs. strange but just like
Ant Man was its own little small thing
by itself so was Doctor Strange so now
the job just like sticking Ant Man in
Civil War with all these other
characters is doing the same thing with
Doctor Strange like mixing his universe
with everyone else's so let me know what
do you want them to do for the next
Doctor Strange movie and do you think
that they should just try to use him in
big crossovers like they're doing with
the Iron Man character like Iron Man's
gonna pop up during a bunch of different
films like Spider Man homecoming the
Avengers films but thus far they've said
nothing about doing another solo Iron
Man film so I think the closest thing
we'll get is like a really big team up
with another character that we haven't
seen Iron Man interact with before which
would be Doctor Strange what's gonna
happen next though is tomorrow there'll
be some new Game of Thrones they
actually just announced that Emilia
Clark's gonna be in the Star Wars Han
Solo movie they didn't say who she was
gonna play though and then they'll be
some new Walking Dead why you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my Doctor Strange Easter eggs and you
can click here for a really cool Tom
Hollands spider-man Home Coming
interview thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five from behind
the screen I'll see you guys tomorrow
you